Brasil está de vuelta en su visita
oficial a China el presidente de Brasil
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva asistió a la
investidura del actual presidente del
nuevo banco de desarrollo el nbd Es una
herramienta multilateral que forma parte
de la iniciativa bricks un foro
internacional compuesto por Rusia India
China Sudáfrica y Brasil formado en 2006
y parte fundamental de la política
exterior del gobierno de Lula durante su
primer periodo presidencial
Brasil está de vuelta con la disposición
de contribuir de nuevo con la
construcción de un mundo Más
desarrollado más justo y ambientalmente
sostenible
será la nueva presidenta del organismo
financiero con sede en Shanghai durante
su mandato la ex jefa de estado
brasileña tendrá como base de su agenda
el desarrollo equitativo de los países
menos desarrollados
satisfacción y alegría me gustaría decir
que me siento profundamente honrada de
ser la presidenta del nuevo banco de
desarrollo y animada por la oportunidad
de contribuir al desarrollo sostenible a
la reducción de desigualdades étnicas
sociales y de género así como al
crecimiento económico y a la generación
de empleo de nuestros países miembros
la elección de Jair bolsonaro en 2019
significó para Brasil un cambio de rumbo
en su política exterior el enfoque del
derechista contrastó con la política de
Lula enfocándose más en instituciones
domésticas como el ejército y dejando de
lado la cooperación internacional
después de un giro nacionalista con
bolsonaro ahora Lula intenta regresar a
Brasil al centro del escenario
internacional